Being an old soul is hard. However, this is often overlooked because we're so good at internalizing our conflicts.
To gain a better understanding of what an old soul is, you can watch our previous video, 10 Signs You're an Old Soul.
It takes courage to be different from the crowd, and the path isn't necessarily easy.
These are ten difficulties old souls can relate to.
Number one: you're marginalized.
Society doesn't know how you operate and because of that, they think you're overwhelmingly different.
People don't always know how to handle differences, so instead of attempting to understand you, they ignore you.
Being marginalized isn't actually a reflection of who you are, but a reflection of the fears of those who separate you from themselves.
Number two: you're misunderstood.
It's like you speak a completely different language from others. You feel like you have to explain yourself a little more because people don't understand where you're coming from.
What you think is truthful and significant might not mean anything to others.
To convey your thoughts and ideas, try using a creative outlet, such as illustration or photography, which are great methods of indirect communication.
Number three: you have more existential crises than the average person.
What happens when life gives you lemons? You're exactly the type of person to ponder over such questions and, consequently, you overthink.
You start to become unaware of what life has to offer and lose yourself within that.
On one hand, you have incredible insight and wisdom but, on the other, it might be downright chaos.
Instead of drowning in your thoughts, let things happen in moderation and find your stability.
Number four: your need for space can drive people away from you.
Space is essential for you, and when you demand it, the people closest to you might take it the wrong way, creating massive misunderstandings.
During such situations make sure to find a way to compromise.
Number five: you feel lonely.
With all the misjudgments you face, and the difficulties you go through, it can get lonely from the view up top, and you never really grow out of it.
Loneliness follows you everywhere you go. Mostly because wisdom and a certain degree of isolation always go hand-in-hand.
Number six: it's hard to find people similar to you.
People often find you boring because you don't like hitting the bar like a normal young adult, or you'd rather stay in and watch a movie with a hot cup of tea instead of going out to a party.
You struggle to find others who share the same, relaxing hobbies.
Number seven: love seems impossible.
The dating pool seems small and dim when you struggle to talk to a majority of the people available. As a result, you feel cynical when it comes to love.
Making connections just doesn't seem worth it half the time, especially if you feel more rejected than accepted.
If you want to find and build something real and long-lasting, you have to be honest about what you want.
Number eight: your philosophical tendencies can be overwhelming.
Your mind is constantly connecting every piece of information to one another.
It's called webbed thinking, and while being able to create limitless possibilities sounds genius, your thoughts can became a mess, leaving you tangled and overwhelmed.
Number nine: you forgive things to easily.
You see things and understand what peoples' intentions are, never reading things just on a surface level
You dig and find reasons for why people are the way they are and, consequently, you have a great capacity to forgive, even for those who don't necessarily deserve it.
Number ten: it's hard for you to participate in life.
Instead of participating in events, you'd rather observe and analyze on the sidelines because it allows for your mind to roam.
And as someone who values space, it's hard not to indulge in that.
As it becomes a habit for you to watch instead of do, you find it increasingly harder to join in.
You know you're missing out, but it's also hard to shut off your judgments against yourself.
Remember, you're a work in progress, it's okay to be scared, but don't let yourself stop yourself from doing what you want.
Do you consider yourself an old soul? If so, have you ever experienced any of these difficulties or have tips on how to overcome them?
Feel free to share in the comments below.
If you enjoyed this video, be sure to visit our website and other social media for more content.
And if you'd like to support us, please check out our new Patreon account or grab a digital magazine from our shop.
Also, for a limited time, Psych2Go is giving away free PSI pendants to those who purchase our magazine bundle. So grab them quickly.
Links will be in the description below.
Thanks for watching!